eu ia dizer que foi só uma entrada para
acompanhar isso quer dizer que é sentir
um cato o espírito santo em cidade
nerd alegria nosso povo é nós gostamos
novo estamos no mundo inteiro
os grandes países grandes empresas têm
estado a com problemas relativamente à
competitividade dos seus produtos no
mercado está mais competitivo
é algo que possam atribuir aos seus
produtos para que seus produtos a bilhão
competitividade de silência am e nós
aqui em santos é também podemos procurar
primeiro temos que identificar o nível
para podermos entrar tarde é divulgá-lo
em talvez tenhamos algum mérito leite
atingidos também fazemos parte desta
festa competitividade que existe a nível
mundial acabar uma mistura várias
apresentações citar algumas
algumas delas teve de ceder ela está com
alguma alguma curiosidade contribuíram
para aumentar o conhecimento e também
contribuíram a fazer pesar e transmitir
com vocês
eis o que nós podemos ter aqui em são
tomé
vamos acabar com um produto algo que
valoriza um produto nós consigamos ter a
ser visíveis no tempo próprio e atingir
em qualquer mercado chinês e tom
tanto o turismo por exemplo fazendo o
cabelo também tem brasil principal a mx1
dela picchu
já ouvi falar que nunca houve e ainda há
ainda sabemos criar países que o
resultado estava um tempo neste canal e
estarei até nós vemos o nosso petróleo e
estamos lá um certo bom é que os grandes
países partilham a ace desde que as
qualificações dos produtos de
determinada comunidade unidade
determinados países e pós que possa
desenvolver o seu país em ajudar as
comunidades e entretanto não falhar
tirar disso alguma rentabilidade asensi
aumente pela cultura
então isso foi muito bom eu entrar com
uma música timbí e será acompanhado por
um serviço que você está um caso e
identificar com o nosso produto
a cultura é o nosso produto é algo
peculiar uma coisa que nós podemos
atribuir à nato musical e pela
necessidade da coisa conseguimos atingir
qualquer mercado porque com a copa ea
melhor estratégia
fred não é e tal eu ia pensar pô cultura
nós temos várias coisas
várias manifestações na argélia que as
manifestações contrárias que o nosso
povo se distanciam cada daquilo que é a
valorização das mesmas
estávamos a andar num interessava não
tocar no tatuquara do gás como a gente
vira para contabilizar como está não dá
vamos identificar com aquilo que o nosso
programa e se calhar vai fazer turismo
petróleo e anos tirada está bem
estávamos e conseguimos desenvolver
nossa cultura nossa fronteira
dessa forma está na nossa forma de falar
nossa forma de olhar a nossa forma de
fazer amor
achei que eu ia tarde
imagina que está agindo assim o cidade
da filadélfia tarde num autocarro
público preta' também tem a questão do
mês depois o vilão chega à pequena
dúvida a identificação coisa ainda vai a
nossa identidade
resta nos a sua diversidade da nossa
cultura
nós temos que é a tranqüila
alguns produtos para que tenhamos
primeiramente subprodutos coisas nossas
coisas nossas
porque se nós olharmos todos à nossa
volta é um time complicado que vamos
encontrar na nova
até agora eu estava a 300 que trata da
china é comprado a forma de papel na
cabeça da língua o bico na bola
tal clube militar
e daí
posso falar com certeza que com o tempo
de guerra
então nós chegado pelo vidro e pneus
também e quero ficar mas esse produto
não pode ser certificado com ele existem
outros meios porque em de facilitar
qualquer coisa qualquer coisa chega
produto atual exigência legal e vem pra
estar felipe vai bastar do lixo e meio
china preta você legal produtos
caracterizando o senegal não criou seu
próprio um dia a china quer tirar a
fábrica de cartuchos e legal
o desemprego se algum de vocês é um dia
em ser o mercado de petróleo
cheguei lá em casa só eu posso vitória
chegando ainda assim rebate beijo lito
doutor da bola e teve o livro the top
ott todas as 34 legal mas respeitoso da
causa geral sérgio deu desde
caracterizou a segurança
por isso nosso produto não deve ser
certificada com vende mais 50 de
acho importante o período de tempo e não
o próprio produto e começamos a olhar
pra não dizer é pá transmitido aqui é a
intenção não é a única coisa que tenho
aqui comigo é realizado o médico tome
casca do coco que conecta as nossas
vestes os pratos nossos para escalas
tóquio mais lógica quanto nós temos como
produzir pedal uma dessas coisas aqui
essa é a idéia que é tratado que
produzirá atribuídos pelo atp que não é
perfeito mas sim vamos ou não vamos te
desenvolvimento chegam à capital do
estado de borno seu colégio passa com a
cultura nossa missão de valorizar e
ficarão as coisas
foi com base em 1998 taffarel é muito
novo
o representante da empresa tocada muito
rápido e eu quero que ela chegue a
portugal figura do gato 11 anos
o gênio é aquilo que faz apologia ao
crime e fugido da coxinha
nunca digo nunca tive sucesso da empresa
também nos melhor e vem pra casinha
velha da minha avó
aí está uma razão dessa casinha eu a
pensar que somos um povo mestiço é
entretanto nós todos nós somos o
resultado de um bocado da população que
vem da europa ainda vem da áfrica
peço
o ipca-15 a pensar qual sugere um deu
sucesso
eu vou utilizar a amm a pensar em com o
nosso povo se juntou ao fazer isso na
música também
mas será que eu vou tocar aqui pra meu
pai quer evitar europeia
vou tocar os tambores
juntei de calor do tribunal é que não
tem os valores de 50 leques almeida do
extrema e do reco algumas tam alguns
fora da casinha velha da minha avó
na música o cacau não concordei e cacau
não talvez
a pedra essa música eu não fazia idéia
de que a música fosse ter tanto lotados
do censo em fundo nem princípio que
depois foi pouco da lógica ea menina
dinheiro e petroleiro bp africa que
ficou cinco meses o dobro das mais
tocadas da prefeita cabo verde e
guiné-bissau tocou em moçambique brasil
em macapá onde chegou foi o grupo de
contato também macau vai passar por
causa dessa música olha não é só ter
usado disse agora dizer que foi também
nas costas
lula que disse uma amiga dela é e tal
então com 10 a primeira enquanto estamos
preocupados em não produzir não criar
aqui exato lê e buscar o leitinho metade
de peidar é tentar e quando vi uma
coisinha baixo da casa que ela só chegou
até que morreu é aquela nossa
especificidade cultural é tem um gato do
for vai ter um lugar dele
após depoimento até que não têm um
tamanho dos tumores do cólon e do tiro e
aprender quem senhora volta do fim daqui
fala de valor de vídeo filme pronto
forte por aí
filho de líder menina negra desta lei
é verdade
kaká também com os receber
nessa coisa por cima da tabela com as
coisas da cultura né galera do tiro
livre de que os figurantes do título
estão trajados dessa forma me recuperei
na gleba um espelho atrás com as drogas
e ao mesmo tempo ela é paga um carro com
o fado nas mal é porque ele está aqui
alguns elementos do tipo le goff 30 de
maio hoje nós outros ou aquela coisa de
cinco anos e nunca falou o advogado quem
tem mais filho tem se mais uma família
régia mais avantajada e tal eu a conheço
e nunca também daquilo que é cultural e
vou fazendo ao mesmo tempo transmitindo
a ideia que aquilo que é cultural
é bom porque só o que é cultural é
certificar de testes e cidade nova
mesmo vendendo aquilo que nos identifica
a vender produto fácil e de jong il um
estilo musical que é considerado
complicado num estilo cabeça à tarde
porque é faz aquela desfile de roupas
piratas não sei quem está está a
transformar-se tem suas boas ações on
por que essas intenções fácil mattos no
time não consegue evitar produzir que
apresenta como música no palco assim uma
mãe tão caro que chamava se ainda a
comentar
amargou uma marrom romântica vai e vem
do japi e levei pau e tem feito sucesso
fazendo nenhum atleta tinha pensado nele
base em cuidado que eu penso em nosso
produto
a única coisa que pode representar o
nosso país ao desenvolvimento
certificado não comentem mas sem
competir de entrar podemos desligar
qualquer o cabo e dizer assim
o que nós temos para oferecer é isso e
virar as costas doem não tem mar só isso
né então vamos começar a pensar cadu é
valorização daquilo que nós
obrigado